قال الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هير سوجا
الثلاثاء ان اسرائيل تشهدون الشقاقا خطيرا
يهدد بتقويضها من الداخل داعيها السياسيين
والجمهور الى التصرف بمسؤوليه تاتي
تصريحات هيرسون الذي اعرض عن عمله في ان
تحيي اسرائيل الذكرى الثمانين لميلادها
وهي موحده في وقت خلف فيه التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه عددا من الشهداء
بينهم اطفال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نقرا المشهد
السياسيه في اسرائيل في ضوء مخاوف مسؤولين
حاليين وسابقين من تداعيات الانشقاقات
الداخليه
وما مدى وجهه الربط بين هذا المشهد وتصعيد
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ضد الفلسطينيين
في الضفه الغربيه وكيف سيتفاعلون نتنياهو
مع ضغوطين امريكيه تلوح بعدم التعاملين مع
وزراء متطرفين بالحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله
[موسيقى]
تمتلكو جيشا من بين الاقوى والاكثر تطورا
في المنطقه والعالم تتمتع بدعم امريكيا
وغربيا مفتوح الا من انتقادات لا تفسدوا
للتحالف معها قضيه رغم ذلك يفصح قادتها
بين حين واخر عن مخاوفهم من ان تقول الى
الانقسام وان تنحذرا منه صوب الانشطار
والزوال انها دوله اسرائيل التي تمر هذه
الايام بمطبات سياسيه وميدانيه اثارت لدى
النخبه الاسرائيليه من مختلف في مواقعها
اسئله الاستقرار والاستمراريه ففي السياسه
حكومه يمنيه بقياده نتنياهو بالاكثر تطرفا
في تاريخ البلاد تتضمن وزراء يتحفظ حتى
الامريكيون والاوروبيون انفسهم على مدى
تطرفهم اما في تطورات الميدانيه فتصعيد
دائما في الضفه الغربيه يحسد عشرات
الارواح بين الفلسطينيين لجا اليه الجيش
الاحتلال جبهتي المقاومه المسلحه
لممارساته هناك خلطه سياسيه ميدانيه
ملغومه دعت الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
هيرتسون للقول ان خراب الهيكل مرتين على
مر التاريخ كان بسبب عدم القدره على
التسامح بين شعب اسرائيل
جانبه رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه الاسبق
يهود باراك كان قد هو الاخر مخاوفه بشان
مستقبل دوله اسرائيل وقدرته على البقاء
باراك قال في مقال له بصحيفه يدعوه احرنوت
الاسرائيليه تجربه الدوله العبريه
الصهيونيه الحاليه هي التجربه الثالثه وهي
الان في عقدها الثامن وانه يخشى ان تنزل
بها لعنه العقد الثامن كما نزلت بسابقتيها
في هذه الاثناء يستمر جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في عملياته العسكريه داخل
الضفه الغربيه خاصه منطقتي نابلس وجنيد
مخالفا في كل مره مزيدا من الشهداء بذريعه
البحث عن مطلوبين وقد شيع اهالي مدينه
ومخيم جنين جثامين الشهداء الثلاثه الذين
قتلوا برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
اليوم ردد المشاركون في الجنازه
بجرائم الاحتلال المستمره بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني كما اعلنت القوى الوطنيه
والاسلاميه في محافظه جنين الاضراب الشامل
حدادا على ارواح الشهداء وفي سياق المتصل
شيعه اها لمدينه رام الله وبلده الواد
جثمان شهيد ماجد النجار الذي استشهد
الليله الماضيه برصاصه قوات الاحتلال بزعم
اطلاقه النار على برج مراقبه عسكري قرب
قرب مستوطنه عوفرى في بلده سلواد شرقه رام
الله
[موسيقى]
مناقشه الموضوع ينضم الينا من رام الله
الدكتور احمد ابو العز استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه ومن ام الفحم الدكتور مهند مصطفى
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن
نائب المساعد السابق لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي مرحبا بكم جميعا ابدا معك
الدكتور مهند مصطفى
الاسرائيلي
من هواجس انقسام وانشقاق يقال البنيه
السياسيه والمؤسساتيه همم داخل الاسرائيلي
نعم هذه هواجس جديه لانه البرامج السياسيه
لبعض احزاب الحكومه القادمه هي برامج تهدف
الى تغيير وضع السياسي والنظام السياسي في
اسرائيل يعني انا اعطي مثال بسيط جدا
ولكنه جوهري على وضع مجتمع الاسرائيلي
هنالك في اقتراح لقانون الذي يسعى الى
تقييد المحكمه العليا وهو اسمه قانون
التغلب وهو قانون يمنع المحكمه العليا من
الغاء او ابطال قوانين
هذا معناه ان الاغلبيه في الكنيسات بعد
اقرار هذا القناه تستطيع عن ان تشرع اي
قانون حتى لو يمكن القانون الديمقراطيه
هذا تغيير جوهره في النظام السياسي
الاسرائيلي ايضا هنالك تقديرات في بعض
الوزارات مثل وزاره الدفاع التي تم
تفكيكها مثلا اعطاء صلاحيات في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله عام 67 الى وزاره
الذين ينطلقون من فكره الاستيطان ودم
مناطق في الضفه الغربيه فضلا عن ذلك هنالك
في نقاش كبير جدا حول موضوع الهويه وحاول
موضوع التدخل في منهج التعليم وحرف هذه
المناهج الى تفسيرات يهوديه دينيه متشدده
يعني ذلك الكثير من المسائل التي تسع هذه
الحكومه الى تغييرها والى احداث تغييرات
فيها تعتبر جوهريه في بنيه المجتمع
الاسرائيلي وهذه التغييرات اذا حدثت فهي
سوف يعني تؤدي الى انقسامات حاده جدا جدا
وكان رئيس هيئه كان السابق قال اننا سوف
نخرج بمظاهرات مليونيه في حاله ان هذا
الحكومه قامت بهذه التغييرات لانه هذا
التغييرات سوف تؤدي عمليا الى انتاج نظام
فيه استبداد الاغلبيه حتى لو كانت اغلبيه
بسيطه في داخل البرلمان الاسرائيلي وهذا
امر يعني في حد ذاته تغيير جوهري وهو يعني
يشعل
تمام السياسيه والفكريه والفلسفيه في داخل
المجتمع الصيد ولكن بشكل حاد جدا بمعنى ان
هذه الخلافات الان هي في مرحله الحسم في
مرحله الغلبه ليست مرحله الحوار واداره
النقاش بداخل مجتمع الاسرائيلي ولذلك هذا
الحكومه اذا نفذت كل كل برامج هذا
قسمات حاده
دكتور احمد انت في رام الله كيف همم تراقب
هذا هذه الصيروره في المسار الداخلي
السياسي الاسرائيلي من المسار اليمين
المتطرف الى الانزياح نحو الاكثر تطرفا
وتشددا
يعني
للتوضيح عندما نتحدث عن التيارات
الصهيونيه والطيارات
يعني التي تقوم على الدين في اسرائيل يعني
ربما نوضح للمشاهد الكريم مساله بانه
لدينا الصهيونيه الدينيه ولدين الصهيونيه
العلمانيه والدينا الاصوليه الدينيه غير
الصهيونيه
وبالتالي احنا نتحدث عن اكثر من جهه ما
يحدث واضح انه نحن يعني هناك زياح واضح في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي نحو
الصهيونيه الدينيه بالدرجه الاولى والغريب
يعني حتى في التقرير اللي همم القليل يعني
حتى هيرتزوك واا هود باراك عندما يتحدثون
يتحدثان عن ال- ال- ما يحدث حاليا يتحدثون
ايضا بفكر ثورات قديمه عن الدوله الهيكل
الثاني وعن العقد الثامن
للدوله اليهوديه فبالتالي ايضا حتى
المعارضه التي تاتي اشبه بمعرض السياسيه
علمانيه
ان تستخدم نفس العبارات هذا واضح بانه
هناك انشقاق كما قال الاستاذ مهند مصطفى
ما يحدث في اسرائيل ليس انشقاق سياسي
الانشقاق السياسي امر يعني اصبح همم قائم
منذ امل طويل في اسرائيل يعني كل كنيسه
يكون لدينا تمن او تسع احزاب تشكل الكنيسه
الكنيست الماضي كان في خمس احزاب على
الاقل قياداتها من الذين عملوا مساعدين
شخصين لنتنياهو ولكن هذه المره الانشقاق
انشقاق اجتماعي وحتى انشقاق بيروقراط
غريبه يعني عندما تصبح مهمات وزاره الدفاع
موزع بين اكثر من وزير عندما يصبح هناك
وزير في مكتب نتنياهو لديه صلاحيات في
وزاره التربيه والتعليم يعني لم يحدث ربما
في العالم مثل هذه التداخل
الارضاء الاشخاص والوزرات من اجل فقط
تشكيل الحكومه يعني همم
السعي الى الوصول الى السلطه بدا يدمر
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه همم
طبعا عن ال- ال- فكره الديني الصهيوني
الذي يصعد ليحل مكان وجه كما قال توماس
فريد من ربما في نيويورك تايم هناك وجه
جديد لاسرائيل الان على كثير من يجد حتى
بعض اشد اصدقاء اسرائيل في العالم صعوبه
في الدفاع عنه
ايه ان اذهب الى هذه الماده وسعود الى هذا
المحور هناك مخاوف في الداخل همم
الاسرائيلي مثلا حزب هناك مستقبل بزعامه
همم رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي المنتهي
ولايته هيرلابيب كان قد وصف تكليف زعيم
حزب اللي يكون بتشكيل الحكومه وصفه باليوم
الاسود للديمقراطيه الاسرائيليه لبيد نفسه
وصفا نتنياه شخصيا
وانه ينفثومه ويقوم بالتحريض وتعهد حزب
هناك مستقبل على لساني زعيمه بعدم التخلي
ابدا عن الدوله وقيامها وقال انه لن يسمح
بما سماه تضرر مستقبل اطفال الاسرائيليين
لبيد اضاف سنقاتل المتحدين في الكنيست وفي
الساحات وعلى الجسور حتى نستبدل حكومه
الدمار بحكومه التغيير سيد جويل روبن اييه
باي عين تراقب واشنطن همم هذا المسار همم
الذي لا ياخذ شكل التنافس السياسي او
الانشقاق السياسي بل يذهب باتجاه انشقاقات
وانشطارات اجتماعيه داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي لدوله هي الحليف الابرز والاهم
والاول لواشنطن في المنطقه والعالم
انت كويسه
من الضيوف الاخرين صحيح ما نشاهده نشهد
سياسي اسرائيل لم يكن بهذا القدر من
التطرف كحكومه يمنيه
تتحرك بسرعه لمحاوله وضعه برنامج الذي
يكون برنامج دينيا
فيها الحكومه وان سيكون هناك وهناك لديه
مواقف سيئه جدا ضد التثليين وضده الاشخاص
المتدينين ضد الفلسطينيين وهذا طبعا
التحدي كبير في المجتمع على اسرائيل
الواقع ان احد خطوات الاولى همم
قوه المحكمه العليا اسرائيل وهذا الامر لم
يكن له سابقا وبالتالي هناك قلق شديد هنا
في واشنط
حلفاء اسرائيل كم مثلي انا وحلفاء السلام
كما هو حالي نرى ان هذه الحكومه ستكون
صعبه وان في اسرائيل هناك قلق شديد حول ما
يعنيه ذلك بالنسبه حتى لمجتمع الداخلي في
في اسرائيل كما قال لافيد
وما هي السياسات
[موسيقى]
القمعيه من قبل هذه الحكومه الدكتور همم
مهند مصطفى يعني تقريبا يوميا على مدى
اسابيع هناك المزيد من الشهداء الى اي
درجه هناك وجها في الرابط ما بين همم حاله
همم الاحترام السياسي والانشقاق المجتمعي
الحاصل في الدوله الاسرائيليه ومحاولات
تصدير همم هذا ما يجري باتجاه همم يعني
العدو الاول بالنسبه
الطرف الاسرائيلي والاكثر يعني اريحيه في
عمليه التحشيد ضد هو هو الفلسطيني
القسم الاول انه هذه العمليه العسكريه في
الضفه الغربيه ممتده منذ اكثر من عام هي
تهدف الى ارضاع همم المقاومه الفلسطينيه
في الضفه لانه الضفه على على شفا الانفجار
واسرائيل تعرف ذلك ويتحاول ان تدير شؤون
الضفه الغربيه بحيث تمنع اي اندلاع انتفاض
شامله او نضال فلسطيني شامل في الضفه
الغربيه بين الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه هي
في حاله احباط غياب افق سياسي ولذلك
الحكومه الاخيره
همم عمليه حمل عسكريا مكثفه وممتد على
مدار العام كامل يعني خلقت فيها تقريبا كل
كل الخطوط الحمراء في التعامل مع الضفه
الغربيه الان الجو العام في اسرائيل
بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع ممكن يكون هناك في
تصعيد بمعنى انا يعني اعطي مثال بسيط جدا
الان هنالك في ظاهره وفي تغطيه وفي دعم من
الجنود الاسرائيليين في الضفه الغربيه لكي
يمارس كل اشكال القمع والقتل ضد
الفلسطينيين بدون اي رقيب واي حسيب هنالك
في جو في داخل جيش الاسرائيلي اللي صوت
يعني قسم كبير منه لحزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
متطاوله هذا الجيش وافراد الجيش وما يصون
يوميا اعمال قمعيه ضد الفلسطينيين هنالك
الان سيكون
ظهر لهذا الجيش و هنالك سيكون يعني مزيد
من اعطاء المساحه لهذا الجيش للتنكيل
بالفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه بمعنى انه
دعنا هنالك في استراتيجيه اسرائيليه عليها
اجماع انه يجب منع اي انتفاض او اقامه اي
محاوله تنظيم العمل مسلح في الدقيقه
وانخفاض نسبيا على حاله الهدوء وفصلها عن
عن قطاع غزه
الجزء الثاني انه هناك سيكون اكثر تصعيد
في الفقه القادمه لانه هنالك سيكون اكثر
الاستيطان فقط
للدكتور احمد عزام دكتور احمد همم متى
توقفت اساسا اسرائيل عن في الفلسطينيه وعن
قتله بصوره دمويه وبصوره عنيفه دون مبالاه
باي اعتبارات داخليه خارجيه
لم تتوقف يوم في هناك حالات كثيره في
الماضي عندما حاول الفلسطينيون ان يذهبوا
الى القضاء اذكر الشهيد نديم نواره الطفل
في رام الله الذي قام والده بالاستعانه
بالسي ان ان وبافلام اللي صورتها واثبت في
القضاء وبالنهايه يخرج الجندي بعقوبه كانت
تذكر ولكن ما نراه الان شهوه للقتل
والاطلاق الرصاص لمجرد اطلاق الرصاص لم
نراه قبل ايام شاهدنا في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي احد الناشطين الفلسطينيين في
الخليل المهندس عيسى عمر بس همم فيديوهات
حوار مع جنود همم يعني همم
في الخليل وفي الخليل يقولون له لقد جاء
بين كثير وبين كثير كل شيء الان نقطه
الحسن يعني هناك كثير من الاسرائيلي من
الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين يشعرون بانهم
اذا كان لديهم تردد ولو بنسبه بسيطه في
الماضي الان اصبحوا في لديهم حصانه
قانونيه 100%
من الخدمه في الجيش اسرائيلي في يوم من
الايام لانه متطرف وهو الان يريد ان يعوض
وينتقم من الذي ما شاهدناها لن جفير طالبه
بان يكون حرس الحدود تحت امرته داخل وحرس
الحدود هي وحده تتبع الجيش الاسرائيلي
تقليديا الان هناك ميليشيات تنشا
بالمناسبه امر اخر ان المستوطنين بداوا
ينشئون يعني اشبه بشركات امن ومش ميليشيات
خاصه بهم بعيده كل البعد عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بكل التطرفه كما قلت وبكل ولكن
نحن نشهد الان ايضا ربما وهذه وصفه لصدام
من نوع مختلف التململ الموجود في الشارع
الفلسطيني حاله الحزن الموجوده امامك عدد
الشهداء كل يوم هي تخفي تحتها نوع من
النار التي قد تنفجر في اي لحظه
في الداخل الاسرائيلي وايضا تحديات
فلسطينيات وايضا همم الدوليه همم حيث نقل
موقع اكسيوس الاخباري عن مسؤولين امريكيين
قولهم ان البيت ابيض عقد اجتماعا الاسبوع
الماضي لبحث امكانيه عدم التعامل مع وزراء
متطرفين من الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده
الموقع قال ان السفيره الامريكيه لدى
اسرائيل حتى الاداره على اتباع نهجا اكثر
حذرا ودقه مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه المقبله
ونقل الموقع ايضا مسؤولين امريكيين ان
البيت الابيض بحث امكانيات عدم التعامل مع
وزراء متطرفين بالحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله واكد المسؤولون الذين نقل عنهم
موقع اكس يو سنه لم يتم اتخاذ اي قرارات
في اجتماع البيت الابيض بينما يتوقع ان
تناقش القضيه في الاسابيع المقبله بحضور
الرئيس جو بايدين همم
الرئيس الامريكي
حكم لاكثر من عقد ونيف همم طيله العقود
نجح الرئيس الامريكي في التعامل معه هل
سيكون هذا المعطى مختلف هذه المره نظرا
لشكل الحكومه التي تعتمد في تركيبتها على
الصهيونيه الدينيه الاكثر تطرفا
الوضع الذي نحفيه حاليا سيختلف ولكن من
جوانب كثيره هو ايضا علينا انقلاب الى ما
حصل قبل سنه عندما كان هناك حرب بين
اسرائيل وفلسطينيين في غزه
والرئيس سبايدر انتظر حوالي اسبوع قبل ان
يضغط على اسرائيل لاخاف على
التقتحامها لغزه وتلك الحرب
ويوم الاحد وزير الخارج
ستحكم على اسرائيل
حكومه التحالف في الائتلاف في اسرائيل
بالتاليا والا ازاي يكون عن يقوم باداره
سياستني بس دقيقه لا لم نشدها سابقا لان
هو يريد ابقى بعيدا عن السجن وافضل طريقه
التجنب الدخول الى السجن هو ان يبقى رئيسا
للوزراء وبالتالي هناك ضغوط كبيره داخليا
على نتنياهو مما شنو ان يخلق
استخدام مع الولايات المتحده اعتقد بطريقه
ما هو موافق
على ذلك
مرحله مختلفه جديده في هذه العلاقات
الثنائيه لم نشدها سابقا الدكتور مصطفى هل
ترى بانها مرحله جديده عهد جديد ستدخل بها
العلاقه الامريكيه الاسرائيليه وايضا
الاوروبيه ممم باتجاه مختلف
ين
اللي فحصناها انه دائما في البدايه
الاتحاد اللي هو بالوقت المتحده بتحفظوا
من سياسه الحكومه ولكن لاحقه من شوف نوع
من التطبيع مع هذه السياسات طبعا هذا اقدر
ات
علق لاي مدى سيكون نتنياه هو متطارف في
سياساته في الضفه الغربيه يعني كل الموضوع
سيكون له علاقه بسياسات اسرائيل في الضفه
الغربيه في اعتقادي اذا لن يكون ذلك
انه لا يسعى الى الضمه ولا حتى الصينيه
الدينيه حاليا تسعى الى الضمه هي تسعى الى
الضم الزاحف معنى بناء استطاني من اجل
تغيير الامر الواقع انت تصوروا ان الوقت
متحد اوروبا سوف تطبع مع هذه الحكومه
تدريجيا وهنا يعني من تجب السابقه يعني
ياتي ضوء الفلسطيني نفسه يعني هنا ضوء
الفلسطيني
انقل هذه الفكره لدكتور عزم هل ترى بان كل
الادارات الاوروبيه والامريكيه ستطبع مع
اي حكومه مهما بلغت التطرفها
يعني انا اعتقادي لن يكون هناك اي مقاطعه
منذ البدايه سيتم الانتظار حتى ترى هذه
السياسه المشكله اننا كما قال مهند انه لم
يكن هناك ربما ضم سريع ولكن سياسات القتل
المتسارع هذا ايضا يعتمد على ماذا سيكون
رد الفعل الفلسطيني وكيف سيدير
الفلسطينيون الصراع في المرحله المقبله
الموضوع بحاجه الى الكثير الى الحذر ولكن
المشكله اننا يعني امام وصفه للانفجار
والمواجهه شكرا
الدوليه ومن ام الفحم الدكتور مهند مصطفى
الخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليات ومن واشنطن
جواد روبن النائبه المساعده السابق لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي شكرا لكم
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]